le gouvernement a fait le choix
d'activer le 49-3 pour l'adoption de son
budget il n'a pas d'autre choix en
réalité puisque il n'a pas de majorité
et que sa majorité est divisée on l'a vu
avec les propositions faites par le
modem donc il est injuste et infondé de
considérer que ce sont les oppositions
qui sont responsables de l'activation du
49-3 les oppositions et singulièrement
les républicains ont fait de très
nombreuses propositions pour améliorer
ce budget qui doit qui devrait l'être
trop de dépenses à justifier trop de
politiques inabouties trop de décisions
qui ne sont pas prises nous avons joué
notre rôle nous avons fait des
propositions certaines ont été adoptées
en commission et ne seront pas retenus
par le gouv sans qu'on sache d'ailleurs
ce qui me motive l'adoption de certaines
dispositions et le refus d'autres donc
nous restons ferme sur les propositions
que nous avons faites de la sobriété
bureaucratique qui permet de dégager des
moyens pour conduire de vraies
politiques en matière de politique
familiales en matière de soutien aux
entreprises en matière de sécurité le
compte n'y est pas c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne pouvons pas voter ce
budget voter un budget ça veut dire
valider l'ensemble d'une politique or ça
n'est pas les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour que les républicains
valident le budget de la Nation
[Musique]